how's it going bros my name is Pippa
welcome back to skate [ __ ] this has to
be one of my favorite games of all time
I Bob I miss cut gam he's an idiot
nice one Bob you did it Bob if you push
hard enough you can do it if skate for
just comes out with no glitches in it
I'll be like the most disappointed
person ever
damn Bob you got the skills whoo go Bob
what the [ __ ] do you think you are huh
the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
speaks obscure fights
I just killed him kill skaters
I'm the skater kada the number one
skater hey ty come back here come back
here [ __ ] where are you going I'm
coming for you [ __ ] bait
yeah boy [ __ ] yeah damn it come back
here oh no I'm fine
Bob Adventure yeah
uhh
bomb attack damn it Bob attack dammit
vomiting goddamn it bomb attack damn it
bomb attack damn it
gotcha [ __ ] hahahaha oh [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ] boys okay so you you jump up
and then you're like go fly on their
wings of love fly on the wings of Bob
blue for a little bit
Bobby's actually Mary Poppins come take
me ah yeah
never give up aha Mary Poppins is about
to make his move
Bobby Poppins
Bobby Poppins away Bob attack MA ah my
arm is stuck let's hit someone with it
notice me senpai notice me notice me
notice me ah [ __ ] yeah now rest me
please I'm so lonely
Bob just drops from the sky like bird
poop oh god what left oh yeah this one
hi
[Laughter]
there we go dammit so close I want to
hit him with my head
[Music]
yeah are they spider-man kissing what a
beautiful day oh my god is that Superman
is it a bird is it a nice bomb it's a
bomb attack oh yeah this is the bridge I
love the bridge no diving [ __ ] please
no one tells me what to do
I got a plan and it's crazy enough that
it might work go totally worked
damn it go go go go damn it I'm trying
so [ __ ] hard okay I got it I got it
go Bob
yeah can't stop can't stop there Bob no
no god damn it that was my chance come
back here you son of a [ __ ] the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] god damn you yeah boy hang
in there Bob god damnit go skateboard
skateboard you [ __ ]
I hate you that [ __ ] happened here what
is this guy doing what what what are you
okay bro dude dude dude your legs you're
an octopus goddamn you're an octopus and
he doesn't give up
[ __ ] alright we're gonna have to deal
with this guy Oh
the [ __ ] is this guy's problem Bob yeah
oh wait Bob is lonely alright press
we're gonna have to end that episode
there I had a lot of fun playing this
game is still fun how the [ __ ] is that
possible thank you brother for watching
and we're checking out all the other
episodes I've done a lot of a lot of
videos of this so I I recommend you
check it out
thank you for living a life that
supports me and I it makes me happy I'll
see you bros in the next video stay
awesome bench bench various bands range
bands